что вообще произошло с точки зрения ней
военных вещей а с точки зрения экономики
и финансов могу однозначно сказать что
этот кризис для россии будет точно
гораздо более жесткий чем 90 восьмой год
и без в общем-то расплате за наша
беспечность вы сделали might map карту
на ней нарисовали все абсолютно санкции
возможность действительно к нам потом
применит санкции из каких-то ребят
стоять во что творится экономически
железа нас уже точно упал ведь кто-то из
нацбанк она смотрит хватит вот это дело
доходит
друзья добрый вечер начинаем наш
очередной подкаст game бы подкаст еще
раз хочу напомнить что такое ген и
почему называется gameboy подкаст дело в
том что в японской кайзен технология
гембэ это то место где создается
ценность для клиента либо то место где
решаются проблемы итак мы начинаем наш
game бы подкаст и
сегодня мы будем обсуждать основную тему
наверно которые волнуют всех буквально
всех людей в мире не побоюсь этого слова
это даже не в снг во всем мире это война
между россией и украиной и самое главное
нас сегодня будет интересовать и
волновать не вопрос войны и не вопрос
политики а большие вопросы экономики
последствия этой войны последствия этих
санкций как это отразится на россия
мирно казахстанцев на украинцах понятно
очень плохо это отражается и будет
отражаться в целом мы попытаемся
поговорить об этом ещё один нюанс
который хочу вам напомнить на генной
подкасте мы не собираем экспертов это не
экспертное сообщество а это такое
своеобразное дружеские своеобразных
дружеские посиделки где мы на кухне
обсуждаем события и что произошло что
может быть как в этой ситуации
действовать при этом понятно мы не на
кухню в студии поэтому тема сегодняшнего
дня это
как входить в кризис наверное вначале мы
думали назвать как выходить из кризиса
но до выхода из кризиса надо сначала в
него грамотно войти пережить этот
кризисом потом только будем говорить о
том как выходить сегодня тема что на нас
надвигается
что случится что это такое вообще и как
действовать в этой в этой ситуации и как
мы действуем в этой ситуации и так
традиционно я хочу предоставить слово
слева направо чтобы каждый участник
сегодня представился и если сегодня
среди нас есть эксперта они есть тимур
turn off явный эксперт но это больше
случайный фактор нежели так что не
подумайте что мы специально приглашали
экспертов принцип подбора гостей был
совсем другой и так его направо
тимур торгов
главный исполнительный директор friedman
холдинг
ирина так разыграешь главный редактор
эксклюзив кизик колледже вес
предприниматель и бизнесмен
абель кори back of thick toker но я
думаю что ты сейчас так да да ну я
просто пытаюсь помнить и морган клич
когда мы записывали подкаст там где-то
молчал и я казался самым поэтому я
послушаю вас удовольствие понятно
сегодня надо высказаться по этому потому
что мы собрались здесь как раз таки для
того чтобы
показать высказать свою позицию что мы
делаем и как то чтобы людям помочь
сориентироваться в такой ситуации когда
происходит вот такие события как
происходит сейчас это не ситуация резко
это больше ситуация неопределенности
потому что с каждым днем ситуация
меняется насколько стремительно и оно не
поддается вычислению определенной
вероятности поэтому это больше ситуация
неопределенности
когда трудно что ли вы прочитать то что
вчера еще казалось невозможным сегодня
становится нормой и самое главное вот
эти все события которые происходят
сегодня они имеют такой шлейф за собой
что вот событие произошло
впоследствии этого события будет еще
долго-долго сказывается на нас на
экономике на все вот об этом мы сегодня
как раз поговорим итак первый вопрос
вообще давайте вот
с тимура начнем то как ты может и больше
в этом задействован что вообще произошло
с точки зрения ней военных еще я с точки
зрения экономики и финансов какой был
для тебя вот как ты воспринял как ты
вообще вот эту картинку для себя сейчас
понимаешь
что это есть
есть два
прямых наверное участника сейчас которые
страдают безусловно больше всего есть
украину в которой люди видимо там сидят
бомбоубежищах или буквально находится но
они и
есть нарастить разворачивается очень
глубокие финансовый экономический кризис
текущий момент и
ситуация разворачивается на самом деле
касается абсолютно всех наверно сейчас
нету тех кто ещё не заметил того что
происходит
могу могу однозначно сказать что этот
кризис для россии будет точно гораздо
более жесткий чем 90 восьмой год точно
гораздо более жестко чем все что мы
видели за последние 30 лет и
точно будет иметь посредственный раз
более длительные чем ты кризис имели то
есть это такой достаточно масштабный
кризис доверия который сейчас возник
который
который уже привел к пересмотру
кредитных рейтингов то есть рейтинг
satomi российском государстве надолго
был пересмотрен по сути говоря до
частично дефолта
по сути россия ушла с рейтинга
инвестиционного уровня как которому она
шла до этого в общем на протяжении
многих лет подряд
выстраивая свои государственные финансы
и в общем имея в целом довольно неплохие
прогноза прыгнула обратно даже не в 98
год риск от минимум 90 восьмой год всего
лишь за две недели это конечно
колоссальная история с одной стороны
сторона очень другая с другой стороны
она столкнулась с такими штуками с
которым мы вообще никогда не
сталкивалась ни момент краха союза не в
момент том как вот валютный кризис 98
года
я просто по себе тоже вижу и по своим
знакомым на самом деле это даже такой
идеальный шторм в котором сошлись все
кризисы и валютный и сейчас я ожидаю что
последует и еще банковский кризис потому
что все населен население за кредитом на
и я думаю с падением уровня жизни будет
очень тяжело возвращать и логистический
кризису по нам сейчас сильно бьет и
вообще то все что возможно сейчас как бы
происходит любишь ли ты как оценивать
ситуацию
я думаю что эта ситуация когда каждый из
нас каждая из за каждое из государств
которые казалось вовлеченным в этот
кристалл вовлечены оказались практически
все
европы и азии и евразии и dos в общем то
расплата за нашу беспечность и за то что
мы не прислушивались к тем
предупреждением к тем
мелким подземным толчкам которые
ощущались мы все время думали что ну вот
пронесет да не пронесло второе
предупреждение которое мы опять же не
услышали тот самый знаменитый тезис
когда говорят что сначала экономика
потом политика и вот политика сейчас
берет реванш и в первую очередь
геополитика берет реванш потому что как
выяснилось политика имеет огромное
значение и когда она выходит что
называется из берегов за рамки здравого
смысла то за это платят все и в первую
очередь конечно
люди населения то есть суп сложного
условно говоря клиенты потребителей так
далее поэтому я
думаю что это боль даже больше кризис по
своим масштабам чем тот который был во
время развала союза потому что тогда это
казалось касалось в основном
евразийского континента
помимо из этом стран варшавского
договора
восточной европы и так далее а вот
сейчас я боюсь что это сопоставимо
надеюсь что до этого не дойдет по
масштабу но сопоставима по последствиям
секса со второй мировой войной потому
что
экономики сегодня очень оказались
взаимосвязаны мы так долго стремились
стать членами мирового сообщества да я
говорю бы мы говорю в том числе и
постсоветское пространство и этот это же
россия украина казахстан
и в итоге мы оказались достаточно
уязвимыми именно всего своей
вовлеченности в международные
международной структурой в международной
связи то что называется глобализация
поэтому не от понравилось как вы сказали
что сейчас нельзя говорить о чем-то
определенно что мне кажется что сейчас
самый главный вызов это абсолютная
неопределённость то есть но тем не менее
хотелось бы
не не так мрачно
относиться к происходящему потому что
извините за банальность но мне кажется
что
сейчас очень много здравый взгляд на
вещи очень трезвый взгляд на вещи как бы
ни было тяжело
отказаться от эмоций и
попытаться успокоиться и принять эту
действительность и только мне кажется
принятие вот этой действительности она
позволит сделать какие-то адекватные
шаги они возможны более того если
откровенно говоря я думаю держание
очевидны а все они должны быть
продиктованы здравым смыслом поэтому вот
будем надеяться что вот этот первый
эмоциональный шок пройдет потому что
сейчас к сожалению миром правит не
столько здравый смысл истории сколько
логика а в первую очередь эмоции и цена
этих эмоций она просто колоссальное
растет каждого абсолютно жизнь как ты
воспринял эту ситуацию
как год начался уже с начала года у нас
казахстане был такой как будто
подготовительный период и мы сразу вот у
нас были события январские потом
началась какая-то а теперь в этих
отношениях между россией и я думаю что
она войска отошли все уже успокоилась
как бы объявили что были учебные
какие-то и резко как-то все переросло и
мы постоянно мониторим там google trends
самые
большие запросы которые делают люди
оказаться самым большим запросам в этом
году был как восстановиться и
если честно этот вопрос наверное меня
тоже так сильно волнует как
восстановиться потому что ну
был к вид все как-то резко
изменилось теперь где были протесты пока
виду на площадях европе теперь протеста
против украины меня такое ощущение как
будто
все хоть чего-то так сильно отвлекают я
не знаю поэтому строку да уже отвлекать
уже не отвлекают вовлекли конкретно было
вообще кантерлота ты твое окружение
бизнесмены как восприняли и они имеют
окружения вокруг 3 бизнесмена ну в
основном себе пытались сначала
анализировать входящую информацию
которая идет средствах массовой
информации но
постоянно она менялась и в целом нельзя
было ли сделать никаких выводов принципе
мы даже не смогли вовремя
предугадать
курс доллара банальные вещи да что
вырастет мы мы мы настолько были
шокированы теми событиями которые
происходили в мире что мы просто читали
и как будто отвлеклись от этого всего ну
и все бизнесмены в принципе сейчас
пытается как вот вы так что сказали
принять эту реальность и уже начать
как-то действовать
как вы в самом начале маргулан сказали
что нельзя ну то есть нужно сегодня
говорить об экономике
отвлекаясь политики ну как правильно
сказали вся ситуация создана
геополитическим маневр он в том что
никаких экономических предпосылок для
того же курса тенге чтобы он был такой
как сегодняшний я не знаю каким бы хотя
какой будет сегодня на бирже он
прорвался на 502 до
123 и все экспортные наши товары стоят
очень дорого ну прям я не знаю какой то
золотой век стоит дорого пшеницы стоит
дорого алюминии стоит дорого нет тем не
менее курс у нас такой себя защищаться
политики нами ключевая ошибка
экономическая да если мы убираем
политику это вхождение в евразийский
союз когда все геополитические риски
нашего основного партнера ложатся на нас
и мы все это на себе переживаем потому
что
по сути вот есть возвращаться к
четырнадцатом году до когда мы
импортировали все что могли там с
россией разные оценки будет а мы 20
миллиардов долларов что у нас импорт
дополнительный стал так как активно
скупали мы товары то сейчас я не вижу
никого смысла я вот хотел бы сказать не
знаете чем мишустин там приезжал вас то
ну и так далее не вижу никакого смысла
равнять и терзать какие-то паритет и
между тенге и рублем потому что сейчас
это не актуально до этого россия не
держа лицами то есть помните мы покупали
машины и так далее в этот раз россияне
были абсолютно к этому готов они сразу
взвинтили цены на все и сейчас мы
импортируем их инфляцию и когда
президент нас говорю там 3 4 процента
мысли по инфляции то еще смешно будет
выглядеть еще до того что мы как страна
зависима от российского импорта пресса
продуктов в рамках я из мы будем
импортировать их по повышенным ценам и
сейчас нету никакого смысла даже нашем
маленьком кофейном бизнесе вам скажу что
к примеру нам импортирует возможно скоро
будет ничего почему говорим о таком
кризисе поставок да как 90 разрыве
цепочек то есть упаковку мы
импортировали из белгорода они в
последний момент признались что на самом
деле и делали в харькове и они технично
там клеили рыбаки мейден раша и мы ее
завозили оттуда то же самое касается
кофейных стаканчиков когда мы
импортировали из россии но сырье для них
вы знаете всю эту компанию have to make
сырье давалось унять то есть сейчас мы
теперь ищем киты уже альтернативы не
импортировать это из россии то есть это
в целом если мерить российским меркам то
там вообще то есть мы со своей стороны
пытаемся как-то выйти из этой ситуации
если говорить о плюсах до нашего
министра экономики гениально сказал
фразу дома ситуация может резко
ухудшиться
ясир но перехожу на политику да вы
видите но если смотреть на эту ситуацию
то сейчас огромный поток то есть не
звонил ресторатор самый крутой останется
только мне переезжает два фотографа из
москвы сейчас актив в наших бизнесменов
ских чатах все пишут что многие
бизнесмены переезжать сюда то есть
сейчас большое количество очень
квалифицированных людей как и творческих
так из бизнеса планирует перебираться в
казахстан может быть они бы хотели бы
переехать еще куда-нибудь но пока мы
остаёмся для них самыми близкими
соседями
ну вот то что касается
политики ну да я согласен что без
политики практически ничего не
происходит и на самом деле
когда между абсолютно права что все
начинает начинается с политикой и
именно политики потеряли почву под
ногами и именно потому что они потеряли
почву под ногами они совершили такие я
считаю катастрофические ошибки и за
которым приходится платить всем на то
есть решение принимает одни люди а
платят за эти решения совсем свет другие
причем мы второй большой момент я
абсолютно с вами согласен то что
мы зря общее отступили евразийский союз
таможенный цист о dkb и так далее когда
ты грыж про курсы на самом деле я с
тобой здесь чуть не согласен потому что
в россии сейчас из-за того что все
начало дешеветь и из-за того что рубль
начал которой стоимость российский товар
становится дешевый то есть они подняли
цену но цена поднять социальный не
компенсирует роста курса долларов я
просто знаю папуля тени они сразу и
курицы начала стала конкурент способны
они начали заводить казахстан и раньше
вот смотрите когда мы были независимой
страной нормальный
наша страна могла поставить то
заградительные таможенные пошлины и не
давайте дешевому товару бы заходить а
сейчас мы ничего не можем делать
единственному можем отрегулирует только
за счет паротита курсов за счет
ослабления тенге и за счет этого
конкурент способность наших товаров
как-то выравнивается с российским я
думаю что вот мы здесь вот тимур да
значит мы здесь объективно против потому
что российская экономика но мы должны
понять все она упала за недель на 20
процентов чтобы дальше вообще непонятно
и но вот смотри с точки на
конкурентоспособность товаров я вижу по
производителям курятины в россии в
основном все сырье производится
на местах и когда идет происходит
девальвация их рубля то у них импортной
составляющей минимум
любой экспорт до них благо в 2000 2014
году у нас
2315 году в россии было много дешевого
рубля и люди нормально финансировали
сейчас через границу в принципе что то
протащить почти невозможно стоимость уже
людей не пропускают у нас уже граница
существенно больше за российская граница
да да написать и пока не забыл на счет
высоких цен на все наши сырьевые товары
проблема в том что до ценно серьезны
теле но мы поставлять не можем сейчас
вот бизнесмены написали искусство групп
как раз таки что нефть казахстанская не
грузится сырье казахстанская не грустно
они экспортируют шиффер это вот здесь
всяких проблем потому что в основном мы
все через россию идем и доусона
российский танкер и понятнее помимо
логистических помимо логистических то
что овладели через россию и украину и
еще про сосуда не откажется принимать
страховые компании отказываются
страховать то есть там еще и санкции
плюс плюс к санкциям добавляется от ники
почему что не из-за санкции или apple с
россией а потому что давление акционеров
и общественности вынуждает все крупные
компании уходить с россией плюс к санте
и вот фонде цены на сырье нашим высоким
и продать по сути много не можем вот у
нас так или иначе цепочки найдутся
теперь при перестроятся я не я не думаю
что
наладится вот то именно в этом сценария
и обозначь как вот ис-3 сорта brent
тексас ее рост и у нас проблемы то не
казанская нефти не российская tablet and
смесь соответственно когда она прихода в
новороссийске порты там танкера карета
там в казахское конкретно но основная
оказалось к нефти the brand уснул с
дисконтом из сша то есть это не urals мы
не помечаем без urals я считаю 20 что
касается шел это что отправляясь на
китай там нет проблем долги морган клич
раз он драть с вами спорить можно еще
один спор не всегда говоришь теряется я
к тому что мы же делимся мне ли вы
говорите помните что уберите вот эту
личную информацию вас есть целый курс то
не следите за новостями и так далее все
таки мне костей который имел широкий
кругозор и активно следил за ситуацией
он уже давно был в доллар ну для живот
недель назад назаровым рестораторам
московским записывали и я им не мой
девчонка люблю посмотрите сказал сейчас
тенге как раз будет буквально со дня на
день и час начнется конец эскалацию и
тенге рухнет и действительно есть и
следить за всеми вопросами то для тебя
сегодня с ней события они не становятся
таким уж большим сюрпризом просто
масштаб совсем уж плохой то есть был
безъязычный прогноз но это прям в музыке
я завидую твоей прозорливости потому что
я за последнюю неделю удивлялся как
никогда последний раз я удивился когда
украина выплатила купон по своему и
проблеваться
вы паладины выплатила россия нет
причем из-за того что она сама его не
выплатила не потому что этот запретила
выплачивали но суть в том что я вот
например последней недели ну просто
максимально удивляюсь всему что
происходит начиная с начала этого
конфликта заканчивая вот потом многими
другими решениями что то что то наверное
уже потом просчитывается но повторюсь я
событие в динамике я настолько
шокирована вообще примерно вот
так что заведу если цепи все
на самом деле simon находится в
эпицентре
потому что одной стороны клиенты с
другой стороны размещения плюс коллапс
фондового рынка плюс на стыке еще
банковский рынок ты в на самом деле
сейчас находишься такое в эпицентре
шторма хотя это и не в россии но все
равно вк астане это тоже де морт банк в
украине как
носу шубам банк в украине работает в
каком-то очень ограниченном режиме мы же
собственно и потом это же не наши там
банков в общем мы не смогли бы купить мы
вы готовились к сделке мы знаем что он
работает сейчас в очень ограниченном
режиме мы тоже знаем что там
существенная часть людей просто ушло на
фронт
но вот поэтому но как как все очень
плохо там часть разбомбили просто банка
вот тимур в
положении твоих клиентов или если вы
инвестирует ого российских удалены как
ты считаешь это все окончательно он лег
у
нас раз повторюсь там слава богу мы
когда смотрели вместе сегодня готовились
там делась раскрыться на бирже нас один
, два процента от общего объема активов
холдинга это было с позиций на
российские ценные бумаги с меньше двух
процентов в него в балансе
это наверно единственно причину почему
нам сильно лучше чем всем нашим
конкурентам который в принципе на рынке
присутствовали но
на мой взгляд
история к сожалению на конечно не
развернется так быстро как она
разворачивалась до этого в какие-то
сырьевые кредитный кризис который мы
видели там четырнадцатом году нарезка
обваливались какие-то рынки возникали
какие-то вещи
безусловно мне очень хочется верить что
россия наверно все таки уже не сможет
вернуться и превратится в буквально в
северную корею по-своему каком
политическом устройстве мне кажется
consoles в обществе уже этого не
позволит поэтому фондовый рынок и
очевидно будет другое дело что
временно восстановления потребуется
все-таки достаточно много безусловно
российская домика создает эти ценности и
продолжает создавать она конечно стало
значительно сильнее с последние 30 лет и
гораздо более эффективны чем оно было 30
лет назад сейчас но но есть такими
штуками как сейчас вопрос никогда не
сталкивалась но если учесть что
резервы центробанка арестованы и весь
вес и плюс сша запретили ввоз на лично
долларов и евро то я думаю не за горами
то время
наступит очень быстро когда введут
ограничение вообще как советское время
хочется границ выехать объект 20
долларов или 10 долларов суточных пиши
заявление уже над почти ввс там сейчас
лимит в этом 1000 долларов или что-то
такое ты не может снимать доллар к этому
все и идет по сути за железный занавес
уже экономической железный занавес уже
точно
то есть осталось только политическим
законодательно признать что надо
получать визу на выезд и все по сути к
этому тоже крайне так как кажется что
крайне близким а потому что все
специалисты уезжают с россии они сейчас
сначала далее плюшки виде вот по ипотеке
ну смешно ной сторона смотреть на вот
эти плюшки для айтишников кого-то они
удержат хищника в следующий шаг наверно
чтобы не потерять специалист они реальны
будут на и на запрет на мы шли они
думают на самом деле честно говоря я
прям какая-то борьба за человеческий
ресурс упрется в запрет на выезд кажется
что тоже это но не совсем приемлемая
история то есть но наверно какие сейчас
ограничения передвижения могут быть
просто советским чрезвычайным положением
которые возникнут ближайшее время может
возникнуть даже шире но
потом все равно здесь на нам надо отдать
должное что я же тоже вот там общаюсь
достаточно большим количеством людей я
знаю что если равно много людей которые
в общем куда сам они уедут ну то есть
вот есть большинство людей своего дома
все равно не уйдет как плов там него то
их дом другого нет а
вот то что вы сказали не более двух
процентов доля российского фондового
рынка это было катается сознательная
стратегия и как вы думаете что будет с
американским рынком потому что тот же
рубине вы уже там года полтора говорит
что
скорость скоро будет стагфляция там
кризис мы кстати он оказался прав
слушать это говорит мне полтора года вы
мне кажется недооцениваешь есть долго
действует говорится от времени вырос
непонятно сколько ты пережил несколько
рек суставного восстановление так далее
я когда-нибудь и желательно и даже нет
стать или нет он
всегда будет расти как и мировая
экономика в первую очередь причина того
что кредит или нас ширяются это же
вообще ну просто параллельно денег
должно всегда становиться больше на это
качественный рост великан он и
качественный в том числе он и
количественно и качественно это
совмещение инфляция на самом деле
совмещения инфляция с концентрации
экономики которые сейчас происходят
крупные компании которые торгуются на
бирже не растут быстрее всей остальной
экономики продолжить расти быстрее
победитель забирает всем уже в экономике
то есть при которой цифровизация
проводят потому что победитель забирает
все и
качественно рост на самом деле он он там
тоже безусловно есть как компания
которая стоит триллионы зарабатывать
сотни миллиардов выручки и они
продолжают выручку стремительно
наращивать гораздо быстрее чем у делает
малый средний бизнес тот же самое
как
может ли это дальше продолжаться на мой
взгляд деньги печатать значительно
быстрее чем акция поэтому в любом случае
это по-прежнему хороший ха ха хороший
истории скорее всего я могут глубоко
изучали как все вообще дал рынок во
время разных геополитических конфликтов
которые происходили
как ни странно но начало острой фазы как
конфликта исторические статистически с
точки зрения американского рынка sli
америка не являлась не посредством
участникам войны она не являлся в общем
никогда непосредственно участнику войны
диона покупать то есть чисто
статистически сейчас скорее время
покупать и продавать блага рынок растет
на самом деле американский после недели
и ты не спекулятивный рост и ну кроме
кая америке не ожидает что твой
необычная экономика выигрывает потому
что расширяется экспорт поставки этой
доли т.д. но я не уверен что этого не
случится в этот раз потому что фрс
все-таки феврале закончил в ливане и
начиная с марта ожидает что ставка будет
повышается ставка но неизвестно могут
они отложат конечно но повышение ставки
это уже больше нажимая на тонус нежели
на газ ну вот опять сейчас кто-то станет
последней инфляции который мы видели в
поддержку нас не то что она была там
условно 86 процентов ставка сейчас 13
половиной лет денежный рынок стоит им
1475 в америке инфляция почти семь
процентов став засос в реальности он
планирует в течение двух лет поднять на
2 процента в течение двух лет
они планируют мы ее подняли за неделю на
вот плавность и
прогнозируемости предсказуемость
денежно-кредитной политики у нас конечно
тоже немножко
учетом вот этой ситуации the forest тоже
можете изменить территорий они уже
изменили они сказали что 05 точно не
будет ему склоняемся по как 0 25 ну на
самом деле 025 4 раза по 025
был один из прогнозов поэтому наверное
поэтому это идет 0 5 гербера вероятность
повышения 05 на ближайшем заседании было
85 процентов то он начал автор же
сейчас а надеюсь процент нужная как
тетенька спрошу когда
циферка слова вы знаете вот не верю я
считал все время может рынок расти но не
бывает такого раны есть просторам
говорить громко и швы многого не растут
да и нас есть такая паслись до монстрик
деревья не растут до небес я лично тоже
не веру и последние полтора года я можно
даже давай обладая писями соотношение
рынков
потому что они на безумно высоких
показателях но последние полтора-два
года я в этом плане нет ни права
оказывать пока но даже вопрос езжайте
мне в этой а я абсолютно прав она в этом
была ситуация на фондовом рынке мне
напоминает ту ситуацию в которой мы
сегодня оказались
я имею ввиду как казахстан которая
всегда считалась очень удобно сительно
благополучной страной может быть даже
более благополучной чем россии прости
меня господи и в итоге получился
идеальный что геополитические риски
внутри политические риски там
логистические страновые экономические
все совпало и
я вот неприлично
зрелый человек как бы не сказать так но
долго живут
настораживает меня это когда каждая
слишком если когда слишком долго все
стабильно я точно знаю что где-то вот за
поворотом случится будут так называемой
пресловутый черный лебедь я они не
апологет этого я я не
потому что ты ошибаются статистически
невероятно невыгодно пытаться искать
какой-то . разворот упускаете просто все
возможности от . разворот всегда
происходит тогда когда вы не ждёте
поэтому гораздо выгодней верить в то что
коррекция не будет вообще никогда чупа
тации предсказать на самом деле очень
многие люди не мое мнение они вот потом
примерно в этот парадигме и предпочитают
мыслить рынок растет в туристы тоже
постоянно растет количество денег
которые которые в экономике обращаются
мы постоянно растет корпоративная
прибыль если мы посмотрим на то сколько
выручки и прибыли зарабатывали
крупнейших американских корпораций там
пять лет назад сейчас то мы увидим что
их прибыль росла пропорционально росту
рынка на самом деле почти все последнее
время у нее того что начнем торгов
вообще заработать вполне возможно ставки
были нулевыми с другой с другой стороны
всегда рк одаренных растет есть очень
много умных людей которые
обосновывают почему рынок растет и
должен расти и есть ещё куча умных людей
которые говорят почему это должно
грохнуться и почему это правильно а в
конечном итоге akkas и не правы и те и
те и либо правые деньги поэтому я бы
таксол любое в основании это знаете как
сыр но когда и на кофейной гуще никто
при этом гарантию дать не может как бы
мы не обосновали гарантию дать никто не
может поэтому в этом плане как бы дальше
я с тобой тоже в этом плане согласен что
все что я беру деревья не растут до
небес при всех разумных аргументах я
понимаю что так не должно быть и я
понимаешь что
падал
это чтобы чтобы он подобно у всего есть
определенная логическая жизнь и
взлеты есть подними но не можешь все
время лететь то что у нас было на самом
деле коррекция достаточно глубокая вот
не горячим полтора года назад на 40
процентов почти равана был очень рад
игралась
потреблять пандемией год до который мы
рассматривали как сама ужасное да
с точки зрения экономики но если с того
момента денежный массового более чем
удвоилось мир то есть когда рынок
объективно должен быть как условно
говорю о сущем можешь а можно вопрос
мари расписки там sberbank of london там
пациенту данную все почитались новости
раздавались и связано с тем же купоном
до который не выплачивается и
ждать ли нам сейчас
дефолтов банкротств российский
крупнейших финансовых институтов вот
яндекс уже объявившего скорее всего дня
но если валютных копать если есть но тыс
во-первых сейчас введен мораторий
запрете по сути говоря выплаты любых
долгов любых вознаграждений были бы мы
сидим с иностранцами российскому бизнесу
запрещено сейчас рассчитываться не имеют
права выплачивает вознаграждение даже
если у них много денег а у них много
денег на самом деле вся валюты нужно
стране сейчас поэтому как бы вы будем
грозит дефолт они уже в дефолте и это
уже отражено в кредитном рейтинге
они уже не платит они уже не могут
платить даже если захотят очевидным
долго будет оплачивать столько
внутренней только долг внутри россии по
сути говоря только долга перед
президентами страны так что валюты не
покидал стороны
внутренней дефолт будет
внутри карман внутренняя и могут 50
банковская система держится
банковская система и кредитный кризис
опять же ну почти весь кредит в россии
он рубль рубль в россии точно не
кончится технически невозможно рубль
обесценился достаточно сильно
выплачиваете долги будет легче я не
между как раз как вот кредитный кризис
сейчас не в потребительском секторе ним
в корпорации вам вот эти экста одинарные
мира проведут потому что их зефир
финансирует как раз я и придумал кучу
опять час каких-то госпрограмм что
кредитовать княжью инфляция другое дело
что это будет приводить к дальнейшему
росту инфляции падение курса скорее
всего я в кредитный крест неверен
гораздо большее зло чем на самом деле
инфляции скорее всего просто но вот
рубля скорее больше он стал тонуть к
сожалению именно по этой причине может
быть как венесуэле
но все-таки россияне венесуэла гораздо
более диверсифицированной большая
экономика но то с какой скоростью мы
приближаемся к венесуэле меня ужасают
другой стороны
многие вещи которыми оптина оказались
невозможно очень быстро становится
возможным очень быстро и
январь 1 тоже
научил и показал многом то что оказался
вообще в принципе немыслимо у нас в
казахстане это случилось когда по городу
сходили с оружием я практически спал у
меня из головы все время оружие было там
ну это этап это тоже норма как-то быстро
причем превратилась поэтому мы живем в
такое время когда все
нереально может быть риан и я вот
возвращаясь все-таки теперь к
политической часть еще хотел бы
дополнить карлыгаш
подходить к причинам дело в том что
мы вообще в целом не только как она
вообще я думал и весь мир
все-таки после второй мировой войны не
отработали алгоритм либо маркеры
указывающий на . что нация скатывается
неправильно направлять а ведь на самом
деле маркеров было много вот до того как
вот это случилось это и жесточайшая
пропаганда когда который просто выжигает
мозги просто жесточайшая пропаганда если
проводить там волге из начала второй
мировой войны там тоже на самом деле
было много таких и в этом плане
есть и говорит я сейчас к тому что не
о причинах алиби не о политике как о
причинах а я сейчас думаю что вот это
вся экономическая ситуация может
привести к политическому кризису то есть
не то что политика сейчас уже политику
как причину риску как следствие теперь
экономических проблем вот в казахстане
если брать санкции я считаю что
в казахстане помимо риска экономических
проблем связанных с сансом есть еще риск
политических проблем потому что если
уровень жизни населения упадет если
безработица вырастет если многие
предприятия встанут то у нас и так здесь
к остальным системы еще до конца не
стабилизирован кардаш ты сама как
думаешь по казахстану какие же ожидании
пор живут по политической части
политико-экономические так как ты
никогда вместе больше пытаясь тебе мяч
передать с точки зрения вот этих вещей
вы знаете на самом деле он просто
сколько это подвинет нос к политическим
реформам я думаю что они просто
неизбежны и по одной простой причине
дело в том что у казахстана все время
фатально везло я имею ввиду даже не
столько казахстану сколько правительство
казахстана все все время фатально везло
сначала
она сначала считалось что она эффективна
и потому что цены высокие были потом
его неэффективность только начало было
проявляться как тут пандемию подоспела
спасительно где все говорили о не у нас
же все это не только у нас все плохо вон
во всем мире
тот случились январские события когда
вот
лед начал таять пошел ледоход но тут и
когда вся страна там была в шоке от
переживала происходящее
начала начался российско-украинский
конфликт и откровенно говоря сейчас и
бизнес и общество и
население там они просто
возможно я думаю что
очень много было признаков какой-то
второй волны второй волны каких-то
событий но
сейчас люди настолько в таком шоке что
мы сейчас понимаем что несмотря на весь
трагизм произошедший в этом месяц назад
у нас в стране
сравнение в нашу пользу к сожалению
вот что касается того как
причину происходящего знаете мне кажется
там все гораздо глубже не только и вот к
сожалению или к счастью не знаю
казахстан он сейчас в общем то там с
разными там погрешностями
демонстрирует одни и те же
тенденции я кажется когда говорят вот
закате демократии или там у и
дискредитации катя кассин это не
демократия дискредитирована а
дискредитирован начинается
дискредитацией института государства как
такового
мне кажется что идет сейчас подмена
понятий дело в том что не потому что
демократия плохая и поэтому государство
там неэффективны а государство
неэффективный потому что они перестали
быть демократическим а вот мне очень
понравилась фраза
чешского политика наши из тех ли кого и
когда она сказала что для европы
произошли произошедшее сейчас это
пощечин
то есть за этим европы европа болезни
сытых когда если это человек ему не
хочется думать что у кого то проблемы и
тиморе там и им гораздо проще было
защищать права трансгендеров там
гендерное равенство того соблюдать и вот
а то что тут целый континент у них под
боком просто деградирует они как-то не
хотелось им об этом думать у них и так
всю крышу и вот мне кажется возвращались
казахстану я думаю я боюсь что опять же
да и bosch pof я ошибалась
если не случится иди читай и еще
чего-нибудь не дай бог более еще более
того ужасного то увы не казахстан сейчас
столкнулся с той ситуации когда ему
просто необходимо что-то делать и я
думаю что это необходимо делать именно с
точки зрения там своего новых
геополитического выбора потому что ну я
все понимаю что у нас общая граница что
мы очень уязвимой что это в конце концов
но не по-пацански сейчас знаете там
выйти уже так и суда кбр easy если не
выпустит нас миг ту но нам нужно сейчас
выбрать либо мы ссоримся совсем мир либо
мы ссоримся с россией конечно лучший
вариант если мы так то каким-то образом
бочком бочку бочком-бочком
учета вот знаете с каждым днем вот эту
коридору по собирают сужается и я боюсь
что не пройдет ноги есть очень
гипотетическая вероятность что мы станем
такими посредниками в этом конфликте это
было бы конечно самая замечательная
самый замечательный сценарий но я боюсь
что для этого партон
нужно иметь боль или более безупречную
репутацию чем та которую мы имели нужно
иметь моральное право для того чтобы
быть посредник
поэтому я думаю что вот в какой-то
момент амплитуда вот внешних толчков и
внутренних тачках толчков она может
совпасть и
все-таки
застенках странно придется делать ну
какие то достаточно выйти и скажем так
из зоны комфорта мне кажется что сейчас
весь казахстан вытолкнуты зоны комфорта
кроме левого берега станут они вот в
силу того что вокруг них ничего не
изменился ни чисто психологически ведут
себя как европа вот сейчас наш оливер
берег сторон ведет себя как европы они
до сих пор там вот живут свою мере им
хочется верить что они там способны что
то сделать но когда я говорят что нужно
сделать мне говорит ой это долго нам
нужно быстро поэтому вот уже несколько
лет ничего не происходит поэтому этот
апекс и социальный выборов придется
наверное делать под воздействием
каких-то не очень приятных вещей но
может быть случится чудо во что плохо
верю потому что давно уже не верю в
чудеса и под правительство все-таки
несвежую какой то я не знаю как вас
называет национальный дело диалог может
быть наконец то возникнет дома
некий прообраз
фактом от голода когда в испании испания
просто показала миру как
то что она сейчас происходит очень
похоже на то что происходило тогда в
испании прямо очень сильно вот но
человек знаете он же такое существо уже
никогда не делаете все когда у него все
хорошо
начинает меняться
чуть-чуть вот и нужны вы знаете вот я
хотела попросить вас всех да вот
допустим мне кажется что вот нашей
аудитории нужны какие-то очень понятные
внятные советы чего делать что делать
если мой магазин
стучать вернемся я сейчас хочу просто
чтобы ситуацию со всех ракурсов
посмотрели и послушали
восприятие каждого потому что смотри
проблема в том что в одну и ту же
картинку разные люди воспринимают
по-разному кто-то воспринимает как
полную катастрофу кто-то как частичного
кто-то как возможность кто-то вообще не
видит в этом ничего не катастрофического
невозможности и т.д. поэтому сначала
первая часть это у меня идея была
построить такой разговор о том что кто
как видит картинку вот чистой ты
общаешься с большим количеством
бизнесменов
насколько очень настроение бизнесменов
бизнесмены сами что думаю я имею думаю
все бизнесмену ты в твою которую с
которым ты общаешься
как вы оцениваете вообще эту ситуацию и
вообще как
прогноз какое-то если есть
последние три-четыре дня мой лонг бич мы
очень часто кооперировались
принимать или есть такая очень хорошая
наверное жилка сразу манекена друг друга
вот так быть ближе во всех ситуациях
делиться какими-то лайфхаками
ну
определенная паника уже прошла все
понимают что нужно будет уже что-то
предпринимать были попытки там
заранее какие-то меры предпринять ну мы
создали свой антикризисный штаб в рамках
катин клуба алматы выработали миссию
сделали
майнд-мап карту на ней нарисовали все
абсолютно санкции и закрасили их
цветом и хотели понять как эти санкции
будут отражаться возможно на нас на
нашем бизнесе какие пересечения будут
вот ну есть определенные мнения что
какие-то санкции повлияют именно на
логистику что-то повлияло и смотри
помимо этого есть уже конкретные примеры
когда вот расскажи про подходу ну
большая фабрика 8000 квадратных метров
одним из больших клиентов является и
киев какие россии и
получается что два дня назад они
объявили о том что они полностью уходят
на неопределенные сроки рынка и
приостанавливает производство полностью
со всеми своими партнерами и вот это вот
этот яркий пример как раз хороший
бизнесмен построил супер современную
фабрику в чимкенте готовы постельное
белье для реки по всему по 7 неким
россии
полтора тысячи человек
кредит по меркам это
внедряли кайзен все классно работала все
еще и в один день просто водитель топ и
все и
просто это вот тот случай когда санкции
не теоретический а конкретно прямо точно
ударили и
тоже и таких моментов на самом деле мну
который мы еще не видим ни последствии
которых мы еще не ощутили но в целом
прогнозы и вообще какие есть идеи мыслей
ну вот я скажу по своему бизнесу мы
занимаемся производством спецодежды мы
определенным уже набрали уровень
компетенции в этом и мы стали помимо
пошила там допустим сразу же перешли на
аренду то есть мы решили что как самое
главное правило оказаться остаться в
игре мы остаемся в игре мы сдаем то есть
единовременно мы понимаем что боль наших
клиентов нет возможности сразу
приобрести там допустим тот же самый
комплект моему получается разбили в
рассрочку на там на 3 на 4 месяц но это
уже в виде аренды и все предпринимают
какие-то маленькие маленькие какие-то
шаги и пытаются которые выйти из этой
ситуации потому что другого выхода нет у
нас там никто не собирает наши более
никто не слушает но у всех есть
определенные там
проблему в бездну члена практически
надеюсь только на себя не доказана
разными к на северных среда традиционно
ничего нового на вашем не мешали
ты как оцениваешь воткнешь куда дальше
это все пойдет ну все будет зависеть от
вы видите опять самуи заложники и
все-таки политики то есть все зовут пока
это муссона обязан теперь о да кабы это
конкретно тому человеку который мы здесь
говорили таится начал понятно что теперь
все будет
зависеть вот от нашей политики ну я не
знаю для меня в целом всегда возможность
потому что всегда в такие моменты мы
росли доживут приятно моя футболка они
становятся мы то есть не поднимаем цены
в отличие от
импорта и мы становимся все
конкурентоспособнее конкурентоспособнее
то есть дай соли растет но рабочие руки
наши коммунальные услуги все прочее все
в казахстане здесь конечно но это
достаточно мелкий пример чтобы по нему
что-то определять я больше знаете просто
думал что зерно вот когда я не то что
оракул но я знал что вот сейчас это
будет и когда мне со мной расплатились
там 150 миллионов тебе на банк попал я
водителю своим говорю а он такой фанат
так сказать
другого лагеря нежели чем в ваш лагерь и
если важно
я говорю своим водителю он такой россия
и я говорю ну там ваши ну не нападет же
завтра говорю банк не поедем сегодня уже
давайте завтра поедем я сниму поменяем и
действительно не угадал на свои сидения
даже то есть человек который вот
возможно ожидал очень сильно данного
нападения он-то не ожидал до который
следил за повесткой и
здесь наверное предпринимателем как
поступить ну во-первых вас я оказался то
есть понятно что большинство моих
активов она все равно в иностранной
валюте либо в так или иначе оценивается
в иностранной валюте на у я оказался с
деньги да я предприниматель что мне
делать во первых я как всегда в таких
ситуациях 2 это части муле ровать
потребление я такой ну я все равно куплю
этот микроавтобус и его хотел пойду и
куплю его сейчас пока там могу бренды
говорить да пока там черт они повысили
цены я пошел ещё плюс ко всему у меня
карта
может бренд этой карте сбербанка да и
там копится эти авиа мили я такой бегу я
может еще и карта и заплатить еще у меня
несколько полетов накопилось за эти
транзакции такого неплохо что еще могу
сделать я могу но в итоге я могу снять
деньги выйти в кэш и тут началось самое
интересное каски сделал невероятную
работу он всю экономику обе знали чего
то есть вот вас нету на lada все сейчас
этот косплей но и все как мы привыкли
затем я пошел банка и впервые в жизни
столкнулся с чем
столкнулся с тем что мне не выдают мои
деньги они как-то подтвердите откуда у
вас как у нас есть основания нет
принесите договор еще один день я на
свечи день прихожу договор тенге падает
все это время да они говорят ладно
хорошо мы отправим следующий день я
приходил они теперь скажите на 100 эти
деньги я гру хорошо ладно пишу я куплю
машину
сдаю дальше насаждение приходил они
говорят когда вы предоставите банку
документы и думаю вообще обнаглели мои
деньги что вы купили эту машину грянула
до 31 марта корж я неделю
снимал деньги из банков что я понял для
себя
что это плохо для банковской stem в
целом нужно иметь всегда кэш этот нужно
иметь бизнесменам простым людям и так
далее мы не живем в таких регионах
стабильных как америка мы мы видим все
эти очереди они до сих пор на банкоматов
стране которые не имеет казалось бы к
этому конфликту прямого отношения и но
нужно всегда иметь как это во первых во
вторых ничего страшного что это когда
это нормально да я и таможни официальные
лица на звонка до нужно всегда иметь
каждый плюс ко всему всегда начинается
пытаться поздно и потребление но ты
должен принять решение и мы как все что
итак я все равно бы купил бы я всем
поставщикам горю а если я вам сейчас
заплачу мы на этой цене за фиксируемся
не говорит да окей и все сделал все
проплаты мы зафиксировались казалось бы
по старому курсу чуть-чуть засадили
какие-то деньги да ну более-менее как-то
ситуацию спасли но мне кажется во всех
этих ситуациях для паса магов сигнал gps
и нужно сидеть всегда инвестировать и
сохраните деньги нужно только там где ты
в этом понимаешь сейчас вот но перед
скрипту идите там волатильность бешеная
плюс очень много там
обманов угонов прочего сами бирже да и
там исполняют и этому для меня не самый
следует нами больше крестьянам относишь
них нету никаких больше возможностей
передавать деньги мне вот есть я недолго
ряд может мы тебе std regular этом очень
и прямо не надо пусть у вас будут деньги
и
мне кажется вот я условно все где я типа
думал это модном акции этот у меня все
это как как попало . спин акций на
который мы все молились на там и так
далее а вот все где я разбираюсь она все
в цене она все растет как пароход это
имею ввиду лакшери всевозможные вещи она
все растет и растет особенно в кризис
просто улетает в космос то есть у меня
прирост по активам по 400 процентов
долгие кризис наступил он только-только
мы заходим него дано только заходим not
be вот хорошо начал женщина мы переходим
той части что конкретно делать и что мы
конкретно каждый из нас то конкретно
делает я был как раз хотел именно не
столько советов а сколько вот как bebus
к что он конкретно он делает тимур что
ты конкретно сам делать со своими
финансами у
меня все очень просто у меня
львиную долю всех мы финансов
представляют собой реакции моей компании
говорил уже несколько раз поэтому у меня
нет этих меня нет существенной части
проблем у меня есть какое-то
относительно небольшое количество денег
которые нужны для текущих расходов и
финансировать проект
ну собственно с ним ничего делать не
надо просто деньги то фактически на
текущие расходы инвестиции я
делаю как бы что что я делала своими
инвестициями защищая свой бизнес как раз
пытаюсь реализовать сумасшедшие
возможности которые появились раз уж вы
и снова став что мы чуть ли не
единственный в рокера стороне которые
нормально работает в том числе мы сейчас
пытаемся
помочь клиенту как который застрелится в
госбанк который попали под санс еще
куда-то пытаемся расширить платежи
многочисленные от реальности с утра до
вечера сейчас засучив рукава просто
пытаемся делать свою работу пытаемся
быть рядом своими партнерами в северной
части переживают
то есть ты помощь украине сирого на свой
бизнес да и у тебя есть небольшая сумма
дней которых до тракта для подсчёта свои
прессинга а теперь такой момент
как иностранные инвесторы вообще в них
восприятия perception of rain in finance
каспию казахстана вообще ты же я видел
там очень часто с ними come from school
и проводишь вообще как изменилось
соотношение
еще до пол дело в том что есть такое
мнение что нас воспринимает как сателлит
россией то есть примерно одно и то же
так как мы по умолчанию союзник в глазах
то если даже на санкции напрямую не
косается то режим наибольшего
благоприятствования в отношении нас
возможно
чуть не совсем не совсем то же самое все
таки потому что
ну
российский бизнес через ten из
казахстанский недели стинга большом счет
против российского бизнеса есть санкции
против казахстанского нет никаких
санкций разница на самом деле достаточно
значением и мы сейчас это как раз очень
очень хорошо на все прочувствовали
в
если
воспринимают ли казахстан как что-то
совсем совсем из другого мира наверное
нет я соглашусь на этом самом с этой
оценкой работу становится ли сложнее
работать на безусловно становится
сложней рогоз но
но нам становится сложнее работать они а
вчера вас не могут
то есть зерно нам сложнее однозначно
потому что восприятие к застою и я сам
лично сталкиваюсь
не такой но я пускал не нейтральное
очень негатив не жалей нейтрально либо
позитив тоже все равно с запада с
америки и казахстан воспринимается это
вот как
естественный союзник россии который хоть
и не был но вне воюет как белоруссия то
меня прямо не способствует ну где-то
рядом и вот это все таки сказать что я
просто сталкиваться недавно буквально
там у меня несколько отказов было по
открытие счетов моим компаниями так
далее только по одной под этой простой
причине что казахстан либо они это
считают нас союзником россии либо они
думают что сейчас следующий будет коза
стального черти на санкции на всякую
фигню то есть все таки у не где-то в
сценарии забита что возможно вдруг
казахстан вовлечете тогда уже все у кого
была большая экспозиция на внутренний
рынок и на внутренние актива не все
безусловно пострадали в казахстане в
россии но опять же не кипре сообщил
инвесторов на тоже немножко разные
потому что все смотрят на разные
компании на разные линии бизнесом то же
самое сырье какие-то институт которые бы
больше были ориентированы на но условно
там протираем был убежищем банком в
которых был глубоко x позировал брокером
которые занимались не знаю там
российским рынком исключительно была
значительно тяжелее чем там нам которых
российского нко у которых российским
рынком чистого бизнесе было как я и
говорил меньше двух процентов но
здесь зависит уже не надо забывать
бизнес есть другая простая штука когда
вот себя происходят такие гигантские
потрясения тебе же открываются
возможности ты либо теряешь свою долю
рынка приобретающие теперь можно вопрос
по возможности изменять
очень хочется спросить сейчас многие
говорят теперь россия будет все через
казахстан сейчас автомобильчики многие
планируют это поставки в россию через
казахстан сейчас возможно какие-то
финансовые потоки пойдут через констан
это реальный сценарий и при этом
сценарии возможностью действительно к
нам потом применит санкции скажу что
ребят стоять в чудо творить
уж я я не думаю что стоит пометка
какой-то казахстан я думаю что это
я думаю что
российский бизнес будет как-то пытаться
перри упаковываться но казахстан не
превратиться просто технического
транзитера здесь придется создавать
собственно сам придется в общем
показывают что они действительно здесь
имеют не просто представительства имеет
действительно какое-то предприятие
действительно ведут здесь копать
торговля что они действительно там
торгуют не только исключительно со
россии и
это безусловно какой-то бизнес сюда
приведет другое дело что повторюсь мы
там очень боимся что нас частым дешевые
импорта россии захлестнёт но вот там-то
поэтому сейчас тут экспортировать скорее
чтоб начнем в тех условиях которых там
которые которые мы поддерживаем
эти города есть кто-то из нас бак она
смотрит хватит вот эту детку да да хоть
и пальцы завод хватит до министр наши
экономики и правительство не становиться
экономики очень четко спрогнозировал да
ведь не хорошо видно все будет и кстати
очень четко
когда ты так поступаешь со своими
финансами что ты предпринимаешь
конкретно
вы знаете я этот пытаюсь исходить из
принципа не класть все яйца в одну
корзину
это просто обыкновенный диверсификации
вот и
я думаю и второе я пытаюсь то что себе
сказать не суйтесь не
торопись
сегодня красные завтра белые потом
батька махно надо просто отслеживать
ситуацию уверить достоверным всяким
каким-то источником и просто включить
мозги успокоиться и выждать потому что в
конечном итоге в чем я согласна с
тимуром ст в том что
рынок может быть растет не очень
качественно и
но количество но все равно растет и даже
если он будет как мы назовём это
деликатной коррекции хорошо это будет
коррекция год-два-три но потом будет
посттравматический рост
после падения всегда жизни на это это
законно законы
динамики как где-то
когда папа по спирали
золотого сечения недавно прочел глянец
диагност законы диалектики ещё никто не
отменял и я думаю что вот сейчас очень
важно дать правильные сигналы на рынок
ес и со стороны от крупных компаний и
банков и со стартовой конечно первую
очередь со стороны правительства что
понимаете какая интересная штука
каждый год мы твердили о том что доходы
населения падает реальные доходы
населения не действительно подают
но
факты вещь упрямая депозиты ты растут
депозиты растут как на дрожжах
то есть если бы то есть на самом деле в
нашей экономике от колоссальные резервы
а их очень много и часть этих резервов
она сейчас банках
люди у нас консервативный для них вот
вот эта депозитная политика на самая
простая понятное и 30 лет и выдалбливали
но 2 3g есть очень выросла за последние
там год два
инвестиционная активность населения и
понимаете почему мне кажется очень важно
дать в том числе может быть и видом
правильные сигнал и потому что если мы
сейчас
вот то самое пресловутое доверие абанин
мы мы я имею ввиду мы как но более-менее
там мыслящие люди я надеюсь и в то есть
и я опять же финансовая система и
финансовый тут мы начали то потом у нас
десятилетие уйдут на то что было обратно
вот это доверие каким-то образом
не знаю восстановить потому что
человеческая память она достаточно такая
злопамятны люди вот поэтому мне кажется
что вот вот эти вот три вещи нужно мне
кажется вот про диалекта и рассказали и
проспер спирально но это не касается
казахстан то есть вот то реальные доходы
у нас растут но мы в каком-то вот с 2007
года в ком-то бесконечном кризисе
находимся и
из него вообще не можем вывести на
секунду 2007 года вот просто это
варьируется ценами на нефть и каюта
геополитика весь мир пережил и
переизбыток денег морозный базе тов
исключительно связаны с тем что просто
экономика является так там всегда у нас
был большой большое количество там до
серого серой экономики серого налоги
как-то и люди все несут на остров
депозитов связан с очень высок ключевой
ставки в том числе просто постоянно
растет количество денег из-за
девальвации зато из-за высокой
процентной ставки к которой все
постоянно виде доходность депозита
начисляется тоже есть какие-то главное
драйвера тоже не не какой-то перетока
кэша и знала фундаментальным драйвером
то является по всей денежной массой сам
еще и кэш посчитаем но вот наверно в
этом и заключается наш мне кажется что
мы
у
нас у
нас наши
одна из причин почему из этого креста
выбраться не можем исключать в то что мы
все время пытаемся минимизировать риск
последние действия мы все никак не можем
отойти от того чтоб которые мы испытали
2008 году не регулятора ни кто-либо
другой мне когда было сейчас дискуссия
по поводу того там стоит ли но
относительно вообще все вот наш этом
денежно-кредитной политики там надо ли
нам еще сейчас повышать ставку делать в
год в россии но если сделать ставка в
россии у нас будет как в россии без
всякой войны может мы в общем то тут нет
этого не сложно добиться но
к чему и привезет ну как чему на
кредитование становится и когда я слышу
мысли о том что мы слышим это же
правильно в принципе сейчас такое время
резки высокий лучше вообще никого не
переставать это согласиться на
действительно сейчас такое время что
улучшилась и бизнесменов одевать нет все
деньги которые только можно забрать из
кредит и тогда действительно они больше
уверенности пройдут через кризис сборщик
например и
у нас а у огромного количества людей
есть ли пока солнце
если возвращаясь к тому что
что в это время делать хотел бы тоже
добавить от себя и от не советую так
худший вариант если у тебя есть
национальная валюта банки кучу вариант
простят меня банкиры
потому что
трудно будет вынимать банки ограничивают
снять наличные курсы валют
национальная валюта ценного lucida может
напечатать уют как правило выдает вот
иностранную вам не встревать банк не так
воет ограничено конвертацию в это грачи
ограничений на снятие наличных долларов
евро и так далее кучу препятствий
поэтому я советую так первое создайте
запас необходимых продуктов я лично это
делают после января месяца когда у меня
5 дней на 5 дней всего хватило всех
запасов доме продуктов через пять дней у
нас кончилась мука и яйца молочка все
начало кончаться я на самом деле понял
что средневековье оказаться очень
быстрым магазины были закрыты выезжать
нельзя я сейчас конкретно у себя дома
запас продуктов делаю во первых раз и
всем советую второе делать запасы не
портящийся продукт of это второе тоже
это лучше чем держать национального
маргу она молодец она не взяла в 90 х на
не видете колготки а два огня я я
поэтому и говорю что молодежи то уже
училась этому 3 выбрать те импортные
товары которые вам понадобятся и которые
однозначно подорожает это средство
гигиены и памперсы и прокладки и так
далее так далее тоже и закупить они не
портятся пускай 2 2 3 месяца запас у вас
дома будет все это вы конвертировали
национальную валюту в товар вам к
крайней мере там буфер в два-три месяца
повышения цен на импортные товары не так
будет страшно у нас будет время
сориентируется как-то и так далее но
по-крайней мере смягчить шок следующий
этап я считаю что
я решаю все конвертируем валюту все тяги
конвертируем валюту следующий этап часть
денег снимаю в кэш
валюте и часть денег перевожу в крипту
сдт это стимул войны это на тот случай
если мне вдруг понадобится выезжать за
рубеж и если наши нашей власти назвать в
частности везет ограничение на переводы
средств ведет ограничен на снятие
валютных средств а за границу надо будет
срочно выехать до этих случаев я
перевожу сейчас скрипту вьезда пи это не
bitcoin это не и этериум и to stay
балконе который привязан к прямо курсу
доллара и курс евро то есть
таким образом меня получается с одной
стороны запасы которые мне потребуется
другой стороны валюта с другой сторона
лично с другой стороны крипто это то что
я лично делаю дальше
отдельно создаю резервы отдельно создаю
резервы который я считаю время
инвестировать точно не сейчас после того
как пройдет определенное время как
минимум год полтора пока кризис не
достигнет на потому что худшее время для
инвестирования когда все падает это как
лавина или осы в горах ты хоть приехать
спойте я будет вниз все время все время
будет вносить вниз поэтому это
то что я делаю это не то что всем бежите
срочно бегите срочно делать это то что я
делал мы сейчас говорим не про советы я
просто каждый кто что делает ты сказал
ему
жизнь вот что то что вы сказали я хотел
сказать
вот теперь ищут теперь это что касается
это тоже сказать с лишних на то что
касается бизнес-разведка ваши то что
касается бизнес финансов что мы
предпринимаем во-первых опять порта
в бизнеса то же самое максимально
перевод валюту
максимальное сокращение дебиторской
задолженности мально
если у вас есть балетный корди то его
надо либо закрыть либо конвертирует
национальную валюту в либо
реструктуризировать либо отсрочить
валютные кредиты сейчас это первое
убийство убийца поэтому работать скорее
с кредитом убрать дебиторку
минимизировать дебиторку
минимизирует склады готовой продукции в
то же время
рекомендую закупить большие запасы сырья
особенно если вы зависите от импортного
сырья потому что таким образом вы
зафиксируете цен на сырье
цена на вашу продукцию будет продолжать
расти дальше не работаете ровно склад
работайте только под заказ потому что
иначе вы рискуете опять-таки работать на
сад не продать или еще что то но
какая-то засада и я считаю что это может
быть будет противоречие с тимуром но он
на другой стороне в другой стране я
считаю в это время нельзя инвестировать
когда все падает лучше не имитирует
лучше сидеть либо в кэше либо в
кризисных активов это моя позиция теперь
переходим следующей части нашего
разговора мы сейчас рассмотрели текущую
ситуацию и как действует текущей
ситуации а теперь давайте рассмотрим
сценарий такой у нас на самом деле мы
сегодня уже говорили о том что казахстан
хорошо если бочком-бочком удастся не
примкнуть ник россии не к украине но к
сожалению это не от нас зависит с каждым
днем эта воронка засасывает и наше
руководство казахстана россия вынуждает
чтобы мы определились украина с другой
стороны тоже давид внешний мир тоже
давид колоссальное давление
что произойдет если казахстан
присоединился к россии
аня ждет очень это я сейчас бы вы про
самых худший сценарий что каждый из вас
конкретно будет делать будете ли учатся
страны или нет я там его дешевле ничего
не делать просто вот наблюдать за тем
что происходит и все тут случае когда
дешевле не работать будет
нет учатся страны вот java давайте самый
худший сценарий к снова присоединяется к
россии как вот беларуси начинает посол
не читал то начинает отправлять войска и
так далее
штуки внутри герб а вот этого протесты
январского он социально-экономический я
думаю что такого не произойдет а если
это и произойдет это все в этом поэтому
люди выйдут они будут терпеть этого
потому что но невозможно устроить тут
невероятно и обнищание они будут оседать
они просто выйдут то есть несут это
власти и оно поменяется и котором
возможно выйдет из этой ситуации потому
что триггер казахстане как мы поняли
один это социально-экономические все и
при данной ситуации мы все обеднеем
окончательно как это мы наблюдаем нашего
но не окончательно но тем не внутри
беднеть мы беднеем сейчас по любому
бомбит нет но не так как объединяют
простые граждане у нас все-таки по
поводу по поводу неизбежности обеднению
и по поводу рынков летящих вниз на самом
деле есть один рынок который летит
сейчас внизу
российским есть еще рынок украины
которое просто закрыться poppixie
навороченным и приму его попал
отсутствуют сейчас есть китайских
компаний которые тоже падает она
американская
есть куча компаний которые растут на
американском рынке одновременно с этим
индекс прямо мягко говоря далек от того
чтобы находиться в какой-то медвежий
зоне по ключевым yandex money там десяти
процентах от максимум сейчас находится в
ход пошли по широким компании дело даже
не в эту сейчас
если повторить вот этот вот ультра
негативным сценарием не будет
реализовываться топ то как казахстана
испытывает испытает в этом году самый
большой торговый профицит видимо за все
последнее время у нас будет сокращён
импорт и рекордной в объеме экспорт и
будет довольно помещать на самом ты тоже
почисти казахстан присоединится к россии
и все самого такое смотреть не
рассматривает если его звали
присоединиться мы не обещаем это ужасная
рассматриваться ультра херовый сценарий
который может быть просто с русского
сказали о том что
мы в и в другом сценарии скорее всего
будем беднеть но вот не факт что мы
будем беднеть в другом сценарии а в
самом ультрах лиловом сценарий мне
кажется да надо конечно максимально
наращивать тогда доля внешних активов и
помните о том что валюта сожалению в
просто валюта на счетах иностранной
валюты на счетах в банке для становятся
самым не ликвидным товаром в период вот
такого потрясения как произошло в россии
гораздо менее ликвидном чем национальная
валюта который в общем но глобально банк
россии банком раздает и она ли у всех
общем то есть а вот с иностранный валют
в полной труба то есть с санкционных
банков худые уже почти из любых других
банков я запротестовал невозможно жить у
дивизиона
поэтому я здесь как раз иметь счета за
границы фляги и реза то есть ликвидность
рубля выше чем едва ли они же фразы
очень огромный были они сами печатают 1
доллар за магистра коридор не в кафе но
есть ли у тебя долларов конечно да
безусловно ты прям король мира сейчас
про себя как фильм евротур помните вот
этот момент когда неприятно на самом
деле тоже нет потому что даже этот кэш
становится невозможно тратить за
пределами россии и здесь актуальность
каких-то иностранных счетов в том числе
какой-то иностранный инфраструктура
иностранных ценных бумаг валюты в в в
иностранном брокерских компаниях она
становится на самом деле очень важно в
этот момент время очень важно но
криптовалюты стоит лукой
это же реально то что помыкает
ну вот этот все так это то что такое
стресс требл coin было глобально это на
нем на счет в иностранном банке то есть
швейцарии такие счета были там 20 лет
назад потом их отменили сейчас мы их
перепаковали чуть-чуть сказали что менее
это не анонимный счёт в банке теста и
был coin это тот же самый на нем еще
просто его назвали другими словами
сказали что это крипто это совсем не то
же самое это другое вот тоже самое ну то
есть я потому что регулирование вода
гуин ты рано или поздно свою анонимность
утра сократится в обычный банковский
счет них пока та не догнала поэтому я
пока это для россиян хороший пилот и вот
этой раз причины почему что он там такой
же инструмент как любой счет в
иностранном банке так уж хорош
ну я мне сказали
попросить с на горы вносит мозге до 7 по
колено откуда поколение откуда ты взял
но когда стая волков уж пытаться
поменяет на
в на валюту будет происходить еще хуже
чем просто при снятии счета в валюту за
счет его на страны я не знаю насчет
российских граждан но на самом деле
показать русским и украинским гражданам
это делается на раз два на самом деле но
он вообще запрещено либо транзак скрипта
проводить как подделать но это этим
просто тебе приносят кожи но это
собственно и пауни галлея история как
полулегально это абсолютно законно и это
абсолютно законно я вечно здесь ничего
уникального нет то есть когда ты
находишься в другой стране ты просто
меняешься закидываешь кому-то на кошелек
заметили кэшем принесли всего сейчас
такая большая среда обменника вот в
москве всех накрыли в москва-сити у нас
фома теме zentai apart нас вот эти
крипты обменники люди сидят к изменяют
это мне на мне кажется это совсем уж
чем-то законными родителям я ты знаешь
вопрос такое что так как сейчас на нас
смотрят очень много людей которые в
такой ситуации что ты знаешь
про жизнь или смерть и
у них нету времени заполнять все
циркуляры бумажные бумаги там ради не
волнует это им к вот мне саму пишет куча
народу с украины просит помочь вы их
лица украины и
я брюс а как я могу вам помочь выехать
украины некоторые говорят
люди из в украине как можно теперь за
край не сумели там недорогую регуляция
там война поэтому я считаю это ну как бы
когда вопрос выживания стоит
счет в иностранном банке крайне полезен
в то же время с иностранных банков вот я
намучился со всеми до странными и
банками это просто куча бумажек куча
бумажек откуда произошли как почему куда
тратить что это просто от какой-то когда
ты начинаешь стрибога в степу коины
мерить миллионами долларов у тебя
возникает такая же проблема на самом
деле как с настроем официально казаться
люди лежит 100000 что в общем все
достаточно просто работает если заранее
это сделать то и но если такие понятно
сливают свои звуковой не идет речь о
переводе миллионов это идея в принципе
невозможно миллионами гонять со счетом в
иностранном по рокере банки на котором
ближе стали о пастушке когда ты думаешь
есть и казахстан пойдет упа ультра
негативному сценарию
притягивается к россии не ко мне
присоединится присоединиться к этой
операции или как они называют военные
операции
вы знаете на самом деле когда в январе
начались все все вот эти события еще до
того как еще до того как
все это приобрело такие радикальные
формы
это было еще вот мирные митинги там
помол 2 3 января я почему-то начала
вспоминать то что происходило за полгода
до этого и подумала как бы сейчас отдыха
бы не верь
почему потому что вот мы там с
украинскими экспертами там постоянных
делая дискуссии с грузинскими с
российскими узбекским таджикскими так
далее и
каждый раз рефреном звучала одна и та же
мысль что в казахстане сейчас
тестируется сценарий гибридной агрессии
я думаю что в январских событиях там
были не только сугубо социальные и
экономические причины я думаю это был
это был адам
первая часть марлезонского балета в
какой-то геополитической игре
вторая часть марлезонского балета
снижает вот вероятность такого сценария
которой которую вы озвучиваете о том что
тому что мы подпишем некий союзный
договор с россией и так далее потому что
с точки зрения экономических предпосылок
вот ну нет уже вот вот такие вот
причины для этого не становится мне
кажется все все менее и менее это
ощутимыми поэтому я думаю это это это и
позволяет сегодня такая его каким-то
образом вот сохранять там
палитра для манипуляции сейчас
единственно что нужно сделать это просто
тупо ждать визита если все-таки так
произойдет вот никто не отвечает
морган тоже все никто не хочет
вы знаете вот я боюсь что я
боюсь что даже путину сейчас не нужен
еще один очаг нестабильности под
названием казахстан или там или под
названием центральной азии лишь бы ни
случилось еще более уже не знаю нет
фантазии не хватает что еще хуже может
быть случится чтобы в итоге сами не
побежали в россию понимаете не дай бог я
не знаю у меня просто беспокоит
существенно границы там на южных
границах
центральная азия там с афганистаном и
так далее там
стягивать огромное количество войск наши
наши минобороны сейчас ведет какую-то
пили передислокацию со своих тому
выявить формирований что-то происходит
чего мы не знаем
вот но я думаю что это самый
нежелательный сценарий но самое смешное
опять же это фактор путина на самом деле
казахстан всегда тяготел поскольку у нас
просто во первых самый протяженный в
мире сухопутную общая граница и если бы
россия выбрала доп другой
цивилизационный путь то мы бы сами в
россию все побежали что собственно до
сих пор и происходило не смотря не на
что это сейчас происходит ну такая
обратная миграция и видимо она будет
расти но мне кажется что есть ли россия
решить свою главную проблему со своим
президентом да не только казахстан там и
кыргызстан и таджикистан на самом деле
мы просто географически просто созданы
для того чтобы там жить дружно торговать
и взаимообогащению круг все портят как
всегда политики
если бы не политики народы нашей не
враждуют народы наши там замечательно
досугом живут
поэтому знаете все упирается опять
здравый смысл но я думаю что в ближайший
ближайшие обозримой перспективе
это очень мала мала вероятность snare
потому что россия давать хочет то есть а
потому что россии сейчас сильно будет не
до нас по сути лились убрать
теоретически самый худший сценарий при
котором к нам присоединяется к этой
военной операции на стороне россии этот
сценарий
никто из вас даже
допускать не хочет то мне как-то не наша
власть понимает что это абсолютно
нереально со надевали очень рискованно
да это очень рисковано вот мини да вчера
только я давала интервью украинскому
каналам и они у меня это первый вопрос
который они задали спасибо во первых
стала казахстана но по крайней мере не
поддерживает россию если этапы украину
сильнее падешь но почему я сказала вот
по моей версии они просто понимают какую
это вряд ли вызовет в стране вы знаете
вот просто в январе когда вот были эти
все события митинги да и большинство
моих знакомых а не просто по мере того
как ситуацию развел снега нет даже если
ходили на митинги они возвращались
говорю это не наше время потому что они
поняли что они ими манипулируют но когда
прозвучала новость без корректировок что
это будет там ограниченный контингент и
так далее и так далее когда прозвучала
новость а вводе кода kb все мои знакомые
сказали а вот теперь мы пойдем а вот
теперь мы выйдем они просто россия
получит вторую украину вы понимаете вот
когда даже мы проводили социологические
опросы мы спрашивали что заставит вас
защищать свои права с оружием в руках
землю земля все говорили я пойду за свою
землю за свой народ за свою веру хорошо
давайте потихоньку
мы подходим к концу давайте
каждый давайте три совета в этой текущей
ситуации для наших зрителей чтобы вы
порекомендовали как действовать
безотносительно это экономические советы
психологические советы и любые советы
три любых ваших совета или лайфхака
нашей аудитории как поступать данной
ситуации начнём жизнь
внутри лайфхака наверно первую очередь
вы как правильно сказали монблан клич
это все свои обязательства именно
которые есть в валюте нужно по
возможности закрыть даже если придется
какие то активы продать потому что она
эти обязательства они могут очень сильно
потом пошатнуть
второе ну закрыть вообще те
обязательства вот допустим носовая
например скажу мы сразу начали закрывать
все обязательств вот у нас есть и сроки
мы уже там набрали какие-то определенные
объемы мы начали сразу закрывать не
дожидаться там заявок на сказали все мы
сейчас сразу он закроем и дальше мы уже
будем смотреть по ситуации как будет
вести себя там валюта рынок ну и третий
мы мой совет это наверное разработать
какую-то определенную стратегию по ну
вот бюджет свой на 5-6 месяцев мне
кажется в течение этого времени нужно
уже понимать какие расходы ну ждут и
более как-то
[музыка]
трезво смотреть на свои возможности
потому что уже там дополнительных
каких-то может быть доходов и не быть а
давайте еще и одно пожелание кому угодно
пожелание нашем праве российскому как
народу что по его ну народу
наверное одно пожелание одно пожелание
это
обратно терпения набраться терпения и
в любом случае
наступит рассвет
какая-то ясность наступит и все это
когда-то закончится потому что ну я
понимаю что сейчас всем тяжело
ну принципе мы об этом заговорили это не
паниковать сейчас очень много спекуляций
на всех рынках финансовая подушка должно
быть больше чем обычно многих из нас в
казахстане и обычно вообще нет и мы все
там в кредитах
пытаемся петьке до машины и другие
атрибуты и забываем об этом сейчас важно
иметь кэш важно иметь очень ее ликвидные
инструменты для меня было откровением то
что муж того что рублей даже не фигни
чем доллар и сейчас в россии
плюс ко всему если у
вас все-таки есть понимание того что
пример вот квартира не подорожала еще до
она вам нужно они глупы потребительский
спрос хотя он тоже очень хорош где-то он
позволяет всем нашим бизнесом чувствует
себя хорошо как право год затем через
этот год начинается вообще просто а
потребительская тишина так вот если вам
нужен автомобиль квартиры река эта
крупная покупка при этом у вас есть
большое количество тенге
сделать эти покупки если вы бизнес
действительно закройте свои
обязательства по текущим курсом
договоритесь со многими поставщиками
пока это возможность сделать а советы
очень много разных советов я не хочу
опять политика включаться и тем не менее
совет нашему правительству потому что
двадцатом году мы увидели что у нас по
жена не может настоящие пожелания до
кризис управления был невероятный то
есть дам или этом столкнулись в январе
мы увидели что и наши все институты до
рушатся по щелчку да за одни сутки то я
думаю нужно сушить умных людей и
принимая какие-то экономические и прочие
решения к примеру вот слушайте тимура
тура говорит очень-очень классные вещи
хватит хватит держать паритет сейчас
возможно импорта не будет цепочки руце
побеждает тот кто умеет считать этот кто
не пытается всех обманывать в конечную
не пытайтесь его купить валюту быстрее
всех они пытаются продать быстрее всех
это ни у кого никогда не получается на
самом деле я занимаюсь
фондового рынка по 16 лет уже и
я понимаю что зарабатывают только те кто
умеет быть последовательными рынок он
разные вы смотрите на один актив
глазами
сначала то в
100 очаровывает и разочаровываетесь
актив зачастую вообще не меняется
меняется струбцина на этот актив когда
он стоил 200 вам продолжить и . у вас на
актив когда начинается стоить 100 вам
зачастую перестает казаться классно и
это тоже достаточно большая ошибка на
самом деле когда риск высокие цена очень
низкая когда цена очень высокая не из
рискни женой потенциал существенно ниже
здесь нет никаких супер очевидных
решений и нельзя на самом деле вот
принять какое-то очень правильное
решение которое вот никто не принял все
считаю что покупать доллар вот такую
скорее всего сейчас уже самого
собственно на доллар на когда общество
сходится в каком-то консенсусе это
значит о том что потенциала с черным по
сути говоря угадать какой-то тренд вы
можете только случайно пойдя против всех
то есть все считают что доллар например
нужно продавать вы вы идёте покупать в
этот момент время скорее всего вы будете
оказываться неправым почти всегда но
любые warmest и они могут 12 лет о том
что будет кризис рано или поздно его
угадают но жизнь у них как правильно
числе вы получается при таком подходе
поэтому повторюсь делать то что вы
делали помните о том что никакой кризис
не сделает вас не глупее не менее
трудолюбивым не менее структурированным
инвестируйте себя держите часть денег в
том числе и на каких-то на какой-то
иностранной инфраструктуре на тот случай
если локальной инфраструктуры
оказывается отрезанной от мира вот
россия нет на себе очень хорошо
прочувствовать те у кого оказались
какие-то внешние активы на каких-то
внешних финансовых институтах они сейчас
очень радует те кто
те у кого все было внутри стороны они по
сути говоря доказательства кораблёва
ловушки для больше ничего нет у меня
кстати очень довольны мои друзья власти
у них free думовский счет
они все всегда конвертировать его
freedom я удивлялся их абсолютно не
диверсификации но тем не менее сейчас
они прям очень счастливы долечу
американские бумаги
краж
ну я могу только одно сказать смысле еще
раз сказать что мне кажется первое что в
любой ситуации нужно ее принять
смириться с тем что это надолго что это
на годы и
понять что одну как прежде уже вот
теперь точно мир не будет прежним
вот во вторых я все-таки думаю что нужно
диверсификация потому что не я имею
ввиду прежде всего большую часть
населения
вот потому что те у кого есть много
денег к ней я думаю если они сумели
заработать и уж надеюсь что они сумеют
там сохранить вот я имею ввиду тот самый
там средний платить платежеспособные
слой населения
диверсифицировать как расходует так и
доходы и
третье это информационная гигиена потому
что мы всегда делаем не правильное
решение и к сожалению из-за большого
информационного шума
найдите себе несколько источников
информации пусть они будут брать его
противоположные слушайте и тех и тех
слушайте все стороны но только выберите
себе только определенные каналы
коммуникации не слушайте все под подарят
потому что тогда у вас случится
информационные пробки и вы вообще
перестанете воспринимать
действительность там той которая на есть
но что касается пожелания то и
правительство бы пожелала чтобы вы
сейчас быстрее выше и зоны комфорта и
желательно добровольно нежели под
воздействием каких-то там
негативных факторов
спасибо большое тебя лишь добавлю что я
присоединяюсь ко всем сказанным словам
действительно ну что заметил последние
дни и что раньше были такие запросы как
бороться с прокрастинации и лени юг или
находить мотивацию
как выйти из депрессии так далее а вот
последний мере я получаю очень много
запросов
как выйти из ступора
потому что ты мне смешно на самом деле
люди получают информацию со всех
источников и они целый день на телефоне
целые гетто телефон буквально и щелкать
или grandeco ты там полчаса не позволил
там уже набежало 78 сообщений все важные
все важные все важны все важные и здесь
начали задавать вопросы как выйти из
пуппера ступора приготовим невозможно
принять какое-то решение счета делать
потому что только начинающий планирует
уже уже поздно уже не стоит уже там это
и в этом плане я хотел бы посоветовать
какой момент во первых
всем надо переходить на ближний свет
вблизи свет это знаешь краткосрочное
планирование каждый день я присоединяюсь
карлыгаш ну во первых нужно быстро
принять новую реальность это прежде
всего после этого надо каждый день
делать планировать какие-то конкретные
маленькие шаги улучшающие твой сценарий
конкретно сегодня
вот это очень важно и они именно с точки
зрения как пробиться через этот ступор
наконец начать что то делать проблема в
том что люди в оцепенении они понимают
вот даже то что мы сегодня сказали
лайфхаки они все понимает и между
пониманием и и делом большая пропасть
поэтому я советую так утром считайте два
часа вечером два часа четыре часа
информационной там не это мне назвать
информационный гид диван выше крыш все
остальное время попытайтесь делать
конкретные простые шаги это первый
второй момент есть и большой ешки
большого основная маленькими кусочками
то есть не стремитесь сразу сделать
что-то большое
делайте помаленьку и третий момент
сейчас такая ситуация когда во главу
угла c или основная цель должна быть
выжить выжить остаться на полу я очень
часто говорю чтобы добиться успеха
первое правило это оставаться в игре 1
правой от оставаться в игре потому что
есть у вас выкинет с игры то вам неудача
не поможет потом еще не поможет вы вне
игры поэтому чтобы оставаться в игре вы
должны каждый день заниматься
конкретными делами в своем отсеке дня и
первую очередь по дну угла это
выживаемость выживаемость выжимаем в
выживаемость для этого нужно разуть
глаза смотреть на 360 градусов
в голове каждый день жонглировать и
играть сценариями что произойдет если то
кости такая атака если так а если так и
предпринимать маленькие шаги улучшаешь
ли ваш сценарий и постепенно постепенно
вы не заметите как маленькие ежедневные
изменения приведут к самым большим
изменением вашей жизни спасибо рост вам
всем участникам спасибо нашим зрителям
должен за то что были с нами маргулан
можно бонусом один попарно все здесь ум
и аналитики вы разговариваете со мной
под деми мур не будет прежней
январские событие вот там у нас уонна
tense был вообще какой-то тотальный
ступор до мир не будет прежде все теперь
сторона не будет прежним теперь февраль
россия нападает на украин мир не будет
прежним что там еще у нас дальше какие
риски дело в том что здесь ничего более
постоянного чем
чем изменение более пространно чем
изменение то есть изменение происходит
будет и будет происходить постоянно
проблемы каждый но самое города или
ощущаю что смотрите любая беда состоит
из двух блоков блок которым мы можем
управлять и блок который мы управлять не
можем но самое главное это не то что
происходит во внешнем мире самое главное
это наши отношения к этим происходящим
событиям если у вас будет правильный сет
или настрой на происходящие события то
неважно какие события будут происходить
ну просто не важна проблема в том что
еще многие видят основную ценность своих
активах и когда происходит вот такие
риски они думают что если я потеряю эти
свои активы то конец жизни cialis with
нужно видеть все таки в себе они в
активах чтобы не произошло ну да вы
потеряете активы ну да ну банк рост
объять не жизнь продолжится поверьте мне
такие вещи пережил я убеждаюсь что жизнь
продолжается работает все нормально и
без вас все люди справиться поверьте
меня на вас вот свет клином не сошёлся и
когда вы вот так правильно выстроится
свое отношение к событиям неважно какие
события произойдут вы будете готовы
инвестируйте свое саморазвитие думать и
развивайтесь я считаю кризисе они будут
приходить все время потому что жизнь
ускоряется количество информации
ускоряется
выбора очень много много принимать надо
решений
особенно в такие времена и нам другой
стальную странах снг так по сами
какой-то вот блин не не родит это
постоянно такая территории есть брат
просил его 2 2 кл час крис 8 ost году
был крис четырнадцатом году дам вас до
этого восьмом году каждые 4 года
российский бизнес вот так колбасит и
вместе с ними и нас колбас ну вы должны
наверно принять вообще реальность такую
что кризис это и есть нашим нормальный
вот все говорят мир не будет прежним аиф
пандемию говорил что мир не изменится он
и сейчас не изменится он такой же
останется он какой был
изменение действительно какая часть
этого мира вам постоянно как как как-то
потихонечку валют санирует мы повторюсь
изменений по факту заказывать существ
меньше чем у чем мы все ждали в это
какую-то либо будущая больше будет
похожа на прошлое ниже хоть на то что мы
себе представляет конечно поэтому желаю
вам всем удачи успехов чтобы вы прошли
через этот путь в украинцам особо желаю
сохранить свои жизни и жизни своих
родных и близких чтобы быстрее на вашей
земле наступил мир россиянам я желаю
все-таки
воздействовать на своей власти на свое
окружение
прекратить эту агрессию
казахстанцам желаю чтобы не поддаваться
панике продолжать свою работу держаться
и всем вам удачи нам всем она не
помешает я и это обращаюсь и q с беком и
каргасок карнизом всем кто нас смотрит
от всех нас мы вам желаем удачи мы вам
желаем мирного неба это сейчас актуальна
как никогда и до следующих встреч на
геймпад кости
[музыка]